[Music]
to start off with some a little bit
about who we are I'm one of the leaders
in the data science and analytics team
at Baker Hughes my name is Alex
Jankowski I'm a principal architect for
data science and analytics at Baker
Hughes a G company and we also have Erin
on the slide he's the person who
inspired us to do everything that we're
going to show you today yeah so let's
get into it
a little bit about our business and our
challenges and actually how that gets us
some opportunities when we talk about
the oil and gas industry in the energy
business we're talking about an industry
that runs on an aging fleet of assets
and not usually those are running at
their optimal condition and that might
be because of when or how they were
commissioned several years ago attached
to that the fact that a downtime in the
oil and gas industry is very costly you
really don't want to have a platform
like the one shown on the screen go down
in production because that can cost you
tens of millions of dollars a day in
lost production so you attach to that
the fact that the the industry is ripe
for digitalization and can leverage a
lot of what we build as AI and machine
learning for predictive maintenance or
else a asset optimization and you get
large opportunities to deploy
orchestrated analytics at scale but what
is the data that's gonna fuel all of
this
digitalization so I come from the
renewables industry actually and there's
a very stark difference between this oil
and gas data rich industry and what I
was used to
I could literally fit in one single
flash drive 64 gigabytes a whole years
worth of operation data from a midsize
wind farm and here one platform like
that it's gonna generate terabytes of
data every day from tens of thousands of
sirs that are recording every second and
putting that data down into a restored
historian just as a comparison to a
usual transactional database that gets
you about 10 or 100x more volume in data
recorded so when we talk about
predictive maintenance when we talked
about applying AI and machine learning
to this opportunities every time we try
to find one of those events or
malfunctions that will lead to a
downtime it's like trying to find a
needle not in a haystack but in an ocean
it's something that you shouldn't be
having every day so it's something that
is not there for you to necessarily
model easily so how do we do this how do
we go about understanding and
orchestrating analytics for the oil and
gas industry so I I want to give you
guys a sense of what is the playing
field for us in oil and gas so we are
built on a industry that it's it's built
on top of legacy systems right so that
gravitates you towards a lot of silos of
different things
meaning silos of data meaning silos of
code and and and and analytics meaning
silos of even runtime all asses
everything disparate and separate so
first thing we need to do is actually to
tackle unifying that so for us to put
all of it into a single roof we we come
up with this unified catalog that try to
contextualize all the dependencies
between those heterogeneous types so we
can actually get logic around the
analytics that we're going to put
forward for our customers so then when
we have this catalog that contextualize
what a model should be modeling what a
data represents we can build and connect
those and create an orchestration that's
what we're going to deploy and that's
what we're going to be talking about
today
so these orchestrations are what we call
analytics orchestrations and right now
to me it's for me is I guess good for
describing what analytics means to us
analytics actually means at the
realization the end-to-end realization
data to key performance indicator of
business metrics that are going to drive
some insights through our customers
meaning we're going to get your data
we're going to get the the proper model
that represents your system and put
forward the information that you're
looking for these orchestrations
would normally connect owed dll's modern
Python code even golang and push the
results into a deployment where our
users can interact now once you have
this deployment you can actually observe
what your user your users are doing with
the both the analytics the data the
results and that's what we leverage to
learn and inform back the semantics of
our catalog so this is the first time
I'm going to be this is the first loop
that I'm going to be showing you today
and you're gonna see that over the talk
I'm gonna talk a lot about loops and
just to put a side note here for us our
crocheting analytics orchestrating AI
it's basically a non dag process there
are loops there are cycles you have to
learn every time you have something
running so let's talk about analytics in
in a usual data science type workflow if
you go and talk to a data scientist you
you can try to Zone in into a
application that is very linearly but
very linear but would represent the
usual atomic level of their work which
is getting a data set pre-processing the
data set into something that they can
feed into a heavy compute machine
learning AI deep learning based model
then post-process those results and put
for that metric into a database put for
that metric into a dashboard or serve it
to the customers but if you actually try
to analyze what's going on and
orchestration looks a little bit more
like vet and you can think about that
linear workflow like the solid lines in
this flow here and this orchestration
which
with data validation actually doing some
EDA maybe identifying the points of data
that you're actually going to use to
build models what models are going to
build and then you go into the heavy
compute costly a piece after the
workflow which is where you train your
models and you keep iterating that until
you get the best model your optimal
model that's where you see sleepless
sleepless nights and several days spent
by a coffee field data scientist just
trying to get the best model out once
that model is out maybe you're going to
attach at the end of it the processing
phase another ml workload you may
classify something you may forecast
something or you're just going to use
heuristics to detect an anomaly for
instance in a predictive maintenance use
case and once you tune that
detectability events you tune that
classification you can deploy your
metric now if you're very lucky
maybe you'll get user feedback and
that's where you start iterating over
your cycles in your loops so you get a
user feedback you retune your detects
ability and you're good to go if you're
not that lucky maybe you need to retrain
a little bit pieces of your model so you
go one step back maybe use transfer
learning and update parts of your deep
learning model and if you're not lucky
at all you go all the way back and have
to basically build on your model try
going and telling the data scientists
that spent weeks on end that tap model
was not great and we're gonna have to
start all over again it's kind of
complicated
but sometimes happens so that's the
reason why at Baker we started looking
into ways to automate this workflow and
give the data science are more
repeatable and scalable way to build
those models so when we tackle a
platform like the one I showed before we
can build several models in parallel
instead of every time building one model
and then two weeks later starting the
next one that doesn't scale so let me
talk about that first
Loup that we saw about training models
so we've a Baker Hughes came up with
this probabilistic evolutionary
framework of optimizing architectures of
deep learning models so when we go about
building tensorflow based models to
detect anomaly for instance we don't
want to just go and randomly search all
the space available and just go and try
to tune the hyper parameters we want to
make sure we found our global best model
over parameter combinations over
architecture combinations and for that
what we do is once we build the model
and we will we explore intelligently a
space we build a meta model of the mode
models performance and then we apply
evolutionary methods to that meta model
which is cheaper to compute so you start
with red dots which are actually heavy
GPU costly compute then you create our
meta model and you apply the
evolutionary methods and then you just
go and burst these gray dots and try to
find the optimum if you keep doing that
if you keep iterating if you keep the
cycle you go from black to blue to red
to green where you get the minimum of
both of your objectives or more than two
objectives this gives us a 10x
improvement over just a random trial and
error search and we end up actually
exploring a quarter of a million
architectures and this is a pretty big
pretty big beefy big model space now if
you think that that is done by custom
scripts that is also not scalable so for
that we use a very nice tool from Google
called
coop flow which gives me a way to Python
eclis describe that orchestration so I
can use Python objects should define the
operations that are going to give me the
initial samples then the operation that
is going to give me the next best model
to a genetic algorithm for instance and
the next few points I'm sampling and I
keep doing that and
what you're seen on the screen so the
first line is actually a hundred and
twenty deep learning models being built
concurrently on a kubernetes cluster and
here we have to be intelligent about
using GPUs because the single GPU is
very expensive imagine having to have
110 20 so we can sometimes have split
sessions and run two or three models per
GPU and that's what we do here we go
back in we optimized find a better
points and keep doing that until we find
the best model but still GPU are very
expensive so for that we try to leverage
out of scaling applications so that
every time we need an extra GPU every
time we hit 80 90 % of utilization of
our GPU in our clusters we give it
another GPU and we keep scaling up until
the point where we finish up the
experiments we finish up the loops and
here you see on the bottom right-hand
corner that we start with a baseline
that's probably supporting other GPU
workloads and as these optimization
starts we climb and then we get them
down while we're just running the
genetic algorithm and we keep doing that
until we shut them all down this gets us
to a level of automation of building
deep learning based models that can help
our customers now in a reasonable time
frame achieve those AI base predictive
maintenance outcomes that they need now
this is not what scale is all about and
I'll leave it up to Alex my colleague to
do to dig a little bit deeper into what
scale means Thank You Fabio and hi
everyone I'm really excited to have this
opportunity to talk to you about scale
today in my talk I will use some
analogies and I invite you to keep an
open mind and have fun
so our challenge would scale to make
everything that Fabio just talked about
operated really large-scale put in one
word was just to be smart about it so we
needed to support that typical workflow
that Fabio showed without that allows us
to continue and not disrupt the
productivity and the process that data
scientists are already used to we needed
to maintain freedom of choice because
there's a huge diversity of technologies
that have accumulated in the oil and gas
industry over the past thirty years and
we have to be able to support all of
them we need to keep things simple to
ensure adoption of the platform's we're
building we have to be able to readily
package and deploy to multiple targets
including on-prem data centers and cloud
and we have to run all of this at scale
be able to extract insights and prove
the value of these platforms so we made
some choices well building our platforms
and the three major ones are first run
everything in containers we tell our
data scientists you can do anything that
you need to do use the tools that you're
used to the technologies that help you
get to your result but to productize the
fruits of your work just put everything
in a container and that is why we built
the depend on docker project which makes
it easy for anyone even people who are
not familiar with docker to put their
software in a container beat Linux or
Windows the second choice we made us
keep compute and storage completely
separate that gives us very nice
flexibility ease of deployment and
treating the compute as something that's
ephemeral even if it goes completely
away we can easily
back up and bring the systems online it
also allows us to scale and the third
choice is to orchestrate all of these
containers using kubernetes today we're
going to see a demo and for the purposes
of this demo we'll look at this use case
we'll start with a data file that has 20
variables and that is really a
collection of 20 time series so the
answer that we'll be looking for is what
is the very best model that you can
build using this data set each one of
these variables can be the output
variable and each one of the rest of the
variables can be used to predict that
output variable so we'll go through this
workflow to generate a large number of
model building jobs to produce possible
models that can be built with that data
set and just for one file that has 20
variables when all the combinations are
put together and we're also using
different modeling techniques so here
we're going to use six different
modeling techniques so for 20 variables
with six modeling techniques you get a
hundred and twenty models that you can
build we're to show scale we're also
going to simulate ten users to using ten
of these data files simultaneously
producing a total of 1200 models and
that is a very very small use case for
us to show you a little bit about the
architecture we've put together to help
us do that we basic
have three layers of storage layer a
layer with core services and the
runtimes so for the core services there
is one thing that I want to point out
one of the lessons learned when we were
working on scaling this up is that it is
necessary to break down the services
from generalized services to specialized
services so each individual micro
service can scale better so in the
beginning we had a generic task service
and that that that got split into
several components of that task service
which is the first one responsible for
watching the kubernetes api the next one
responsible for creating model jobs the
next one responsible for collecting the
results from jobs that have completed
the last one responsible for cleaning up
after everybody so I can take the whole
time of this talk just going over the
points in this slide but I like doing
things a lot more than talking about
them so we're just going to hit the high
points lessons we've learned from this
exercise large-scale doesn't come out of
the box you will be required to work for
it and it's not a manual thing if you
try to repeat and do everything manually
you'll get very tired pretty quickly and
you have to you'll start making
significant mistakes so automation and
scripting are key we already talked
about breaking down services to micro
services monolith services don't lend
themselves to scale and when you're
talking about large scale
a hundred ex you have to be prepared to
redesign and rethink what you're doing
and maybe rewrite several times the
debates between cloud managed and self
managed kubernetes I'm not going to go
too much into that but all I want to say
is that using gke can save you a lot of
sleep there is this one really useful
kubernetes api called the watch API
which lets you monitor the status of
your pods and get real-time events as
changes happen in your cluster so we're
making use of that in our demo oh so we
had made an assumption that it is enough
to they just scale my service in
kubernetes and then traffic will be
distributed evenly and all the pods will
will be happy to handle an equal amount
of traffic that is not the case you
actually have to do some work to get
proper load balancing in kubernetes we
were seeing that some of our pods were
getting so much traffic they were
literally killed and had to restart and
others were just sitting there so using
an void proxy solved that problem using
the Google native cloud load balancers
solved that problem I want to caution
you watch out for the less-is-more
paradox
so in our desire to scale everything so
high we said all right let's run a
hundred of this service and a thousand
of that service in 2000 of that one we
scheduled we even scaled one up to eight
thousand and things actually slowed down
instead of giving us better results so
you really have to think and optimize
for what is good for your system and
realize that sometimes
less is more last lesson I learned that
will actually bring me back to the next
slide is sometimes one kubernetes
cluster is not enough to accomplish what
you're trying to do so when that's the
case just use many so for the purposes
of today's demo we have built for you a
cluster of kubernetes clusters what you
see here is our master kubernetes
cluster that has all of the services
that I showed you in the previous slide
scaled up and this in itself gives you a
scalable system because you can scale
horizontally by running more nodes in
your cluster you can scale vertically by
running larger nodes in your cluster but
what we've done gives you another degree
of freedom because you can run as many
kubernetes clusters as you want to
handle your load so now you can spread
your system really wide and by the way
remember how I talked about self-managed
versus gke here we have done both so it
is not required we can run all of our
workloads on GK or all of them on
kubernetes but we're going to show you
both just because we can so this is an
example of one of our gke clusters it
has a hundred nodes and it's ready for
us to run workloads on I'm going to zoom
out a little bit these are five gke
clusters
so remember how I said I'll make some
analogies what does this remind you of
let me zoom out one more time on the top
live 5gk clusters in the middle is our
management cluster and on the bottom are
5 self-managed clusters I don't know
about you but to me this looks like a
skyscraper ok let's take a look at how
everything looks on screen so I have
split my screen here into just so I can
show you our management cluster I will
well this is really slow I just want to
show you that things are actually
running here I'm also going to show you
at what scale we're running our core
services and let me zoom this out a
little bit so you can say some instances
have a thousand some 500 instances now
we have modified the kubernetes
dashboard so we can also visually show
you what this scale looks like so we've
added this graph tab to the kubernetes
dashboard and that is the visual
representation of what we just saw
that's only the master cluster I will
zoom into this area here so each of the
triangles in this chart is a service and
each of the dots are pods from that
service that are running in the cluster
let's take a look at the worker clusters
so here I have let me show you this will
will use a very nifty tool called cube
CTX lets you easily show what are the
kubernetes context that you're looking
at so on the left you will see each of
these sessions pointing to one of the
gke clusters one through five and on the
right we have five self-managed
kubernetes contexts so I'm going to show
you what's running in these clusters by
watching the command cube CT I'll get
pods and what's running is absolutely
nothing but that's a good thing because
we can't visualize it yet so if we were
to use that kubernetes dashboard and
wanting to visualize a low workload that
is running in ten kubernetes clusters
what are we going to do install it in
each one of the clusters and then have
ten screens up then what if we had a
hundred kubernetes clusters that doesn't
scale so we've built a custom UI that
aggregates all the information from the
clusters and displays it in a single
user interface right now I'm just going
to
show you that one cluster we have
running pods that's the master cluster
let me pull the dots together a little
bit slow down make them bigger so these
are the service pods that we have
running in the master cluster we're
going to see what okay
we're going to use docker compose to
simulate these ten different users each
of them using a different data file of
twenty variables each to submit to the
guided build API a hundred and twenty
models so let me see what this will
remind you of
it's colorful isn't it isn't it funny
how things in the real world remind us
of things that scale in the virtual
world so here is the workload of these
jobs that we submitted being distributed
between all of the kubernetes clusters
and
let's take a look at our rainbow here
well as it happens the demo gods are not
always in favor of us but that is why we
have screenshots you can see the
workload here much better anyway and
this is what these 1200 models look like
when they got created in all the 10
kubernetes clusters so I once saw a
demonstration of somebody building a lot
of containers and running a lot of
containers in a cluster that
visualization was beautiful and it
honestly looked to me like a galaxy so
when I saw this one for the first time
at scale I thought that each one of
these little clusters looks like a
galaxy so I made a comment to my team
guys I think we've inadvertently
modelled the universe if you want to see
this demo at bigger scale 10x and 100x I
invite you after this talk to move to
the next hallway room 11 where you'll be
able to see this running at much larger
scale
so let me see if we can I'm going to
stop it and and we'll see this is yeah
things are being created but yeah it's
beautiful isn't it the ocean of data
that Fabio talked about is real and
being able to extract that answer what
is the best model what is the meaningful
information in this ocean of data is
actually not very straightforward but
that is the reason why we did all of
this so let me run a query here so we
can get yep you can get our answer
the answer will come up once all the
metrics get accumulated and ranked
because we started with a completely
blank system we don't have the answer
yet however what I wanted to point out
is that as in many things in science the
answer to the question what is the best
model is it depends if you use the
criteria of root mean square error then
the answer is one if you use max
percentage error then you might get a
different model or average percentage
error I do want to leave you with a few
things to take home
first of all real world use cases
require scale we demonstrated
orchestration and analytics we showed
you screenshots of scale we use docker
kubernetes tensorflow and cube flow on
scalable infrastructure and managed
services from Google cloud I also want
to leave you with something that I'd
like you to remember this talk by a year
two years from now when you think back
about Fabian Alex from BH EE that talked
about orchestrating of containers and
and scaling things up this is the one
talk where you saw how to use
skyscrapers and rainbows to model the
galaxy
I would like to read out some names here
on this slide we have a small thank you
for some big names Varun Andre
Renato Sharia Christian Imran Morley
Madhavan Simon trying Rashid Alex
Kelsey Sina young Ning tad Josh Scott
will and many more
thank you for collaborating and
encouraging us we have a page full of
references for you anyone who would like
to read more and who has doubts about
what we're showing here today please
refer to these links and you can always
get in touch with Fabio and I offline
but if you have any questions that you
would like to ask us now please pick up
a mic and we'll do the best we can to
answer thank you
a network connectivity issue prevented
the demonstration in this session from
working flawlessly
the issue was mitigated immediately
after the presentation in order to
provide you the full experience of this
amazing capability we have recorded the
following additional video
you
[Music]